[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
in what is very quickly becoming one of
the major stories of 2016 former
producer Louis will be calling into the
bonus show today I'm sorry no that's
true but what at the actual big story is
that we have now learned according to a
number of American intelligence agencies
adding to the story from earlier this
week that Russian President Vladimir
Putin a former KGB agent was personally
involved in the Russian hacking meant to
hurt Hillary Clinton in her campaign
against Donald Trump Russian involvement
in the election of Donald Trump uh uh
has become now a fundamental turning
point I would argue in terms of the
concept of sovereign American elections
US intelligence officials have a quote
high level of confidence that Putin was
personally involved in the hacking that
took place two senior US officials with
direct access to the information say
that the new intelligence shows that
Putin was personally directing how the
hacked material should be leaked and how
the hacked material should be used and
this comes from diplomatic sources and
spies working for American allies
according to American officials and
here's the most revealing part this
seems to have started not because
Vladimir Putin wanted Donald Trump to
win per se but because of light amir
putin so-called vendetta against hillary
clinton and then it reportedly turned
into an effort to just more generally
show how corrupt american politics is
and quote split off key american allies
by creating the image that other
countries couldn't depend on the u.s. to
be a credible global global leader
anymore it succeeded congratulations to
Vladimir Putin who Mitt Romney said in
26 2012 Russia and Putin the greatest
geopolitical foe of the United States as
we've been talking about for a long time
now we talk Pat about who is going to be
the leader of the free world when
President Trump is president of the u.s.
it's not going to be Trump and run
she has successfully undermine the idea
of the US as a credible global leader
with Donald Trump they they succeed
excuse me they succeeded who who thought
that Mitt Romney we would be right on
that point that Russia would be the
greatest geopolitical threat it turns
out that the election of Donald Trump
has verified that ultimately the CIA did
say by the end of this little project
for Vladimir Putin they did proactively
want to elect Trump but that's not how
it started it started just as hurting
Hillary and we now know this goes way
further than intelligence suggested back
in October the US with solid information
time Putin to the operation this is
major major major this is one of the
most successful campaigns that we have
ever seen in the history of the United
States to meddle in American elections
by a foreign power now first of all at a
sort of micro level do Trump supporters
realize how embarrassing it is that
their guy is a puppet that was helped by
a foreign power called our greatest
geopolitical foe just four years ago one
of my cousins made a good point about
this on Facebook uh saying you know the
US has actually been interfering with
elections in other parts of the world
for a very long time not that many
people in the u.s. cared that we were
influencing other countries elections so
maybe they won't care that another
country influenced hours I don't know
well this is the interesting republican
talking point going around now that no
voter was actually influenced by what
the kremlin had to say right and what
russia wanted to be the outcome of the
election yet it yet go step further than
that is what they hacked that would give
a false impression of hillary clinton
and cause them to change their mind in
vote for Donald Trump yeah on Twitter
I've got all these trumpets saying David
I voted for Trump and it had nothing to
do with what Putin said this isn't about
what Putin said right Trump won by 58
thousand votes across three key states
while losing hugely in the popular vote
and it's abundantly clear that were it
not for this coordinated smear campaign
by the President of Russia a lifelong
KGB agent that Donald Trump would be
very unlikely to have won that
election and conservatives talk about
American sovereignty even if the guy
that bamboozled you into voting for him
one and you like that he won in part
because of another country's operations
for their own fun and games an American
sovereignty over our own elections has
been completely compromised this will be
written about in history books this is
historic Vladimir Putin's involvement
here uh to to get a clueless reality
show buffoon elected who is now
appointing Russia friendly business
buddies to run the country and will be
getting to decide on Supreme Court
justices Putin and his buddies are
probably laughing hysterically every day
aren't they Pat I mean they must just be
yucking it up over there yeah they're
very happy with the outcome so it seems
they got a country around 325 million
people to elect an authoritarian strong
man who has no idea what he's doing in
Vladimir Putin we know has wanted to be
seen as a powerful uh of force in the
world and I think that he has achieved
that he Russian hacking has changed the
direction of the United States and I
want to go further for a second I don't
believe for a second the Donald Trump
didn't know about this I'm not saying
that Donald Trump was coordinating with
Russia but we can't really believe Pat
that Paul mana for working for Trump
direct connections to the Kremlin uh
prior attempts at business dealings with
Russia Trump connections to Russian
billionaires etcetera it's very hard for
me to believe that Trump was completely
in the dark about what Russia was doing
and now you can even take a look at his
cabinet picks because his choice for
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson has a
long history with dealing with aamir
Putin another story line here is all of
a sudden Republicans don't think
Russia's that bad right nothing material
has changed since in 2012 Romney said
Russia's our biggest geopolitical foe
Republicans didn't really argue against
that then nothing has materially changed
except for the fact that now we have
that country that was our greatest
geopolitical foe having acted to help
Donald Trump win remember when Trump
during the campaign said the world is
laughing at us turns out he was right
but it has nothing at all to do with
President
Obama scientists are frantically copying
climate data fearing that it might be
deleted or made to disappear under
President Donald Trump they're so afraid
are these scientists that decades of
data that they've been working on could
be eliminated under a Donald Trump
administration that they've established
independent servers or they can copy off
tons of government data to try to
protect it from potential political
interference this includes an effort of
guerrilla archiving in Toronto this
includes meetings at the University of
Pennsylvania try to figure out how to
download as much federal data as
possible this includes scientists and
database experts that are collaborating
to figure out how to create a sort of
safe harbor for scientific information
and why is this happening well it's
happening because president-elect Donald
Trump is nominated this ever-growing
list of camp cabinet members who have
questioned the scientific consensus on
global warming the transition team at
the Department of Energy has demanded
the names of agency officials who were
involved in international climate talks
to work on what we know to be the
scientific basis for Obama
administration regulations of carbon
emissions they want names Pat and I
understand the fear yeah I don't think
they're being paranoid at all if you
look at Trump's position on climate
change in his more authoritarian
tendencies like cracking down on a free
flow of information one Trump advisor
suggested that NASA should not be
allowed to conduct climate research
anymore because it's become too
political and of course Trump himself is
called cute human-caused climate change
a hoax perpetrated by the Chinese for
the benefit of the Chinese economy and
Pat said he doesn't think it's paranoia
is it paranoia or preparedness the
scientist involved are saying no no no
this is preparedness this is one of the
major issues of our time climate change
in what we're doing to our planet and
according to a Sierra Club report when
Trump assumes the presidency on january
twentieth he will be the only head of
state in the world to deny what we know
as mainstream consensus climate science
and that includes Kim jong-un of North
Korea nor
Korea is more science-based than Trump
on the issue of climate change and look
at the wide coalition of world leaders
who got together to uh sign the Paris
climate Accord and now Trump is even
threatened to pull out of that there's
precedent for the fear that scientists
have though because Stephen Harper did
something similar in Canada where he
attempted to silence climate scientists
and in a few cases some data sets were
taken offline all together and forget
for a second about the issue of climate
change specifically if we ever have a
president deleting data from research
that doesn't agree with the position of
their administration we've got far
bigger problems on our hands and you
know what if they appoint cabinet
members ideologically opposed to the
departments that they had that would be
really bad also oh wait a second Rick
Perry to the Department of Energy who
doesn't think that we should have a
Department of Energy Scott Pruett to the
Environmental Protection Agency a guy
whose career has been based on the
opposite of protecting the environment
that's a big problem we are really
really in for it you're going to like
this video this is what i'm calling the
trump clown of the day now during the
presidential campaign the Trump clown of
the day was very often one of trumps
spokespeople Katrina Pierson for example
and Healy Bumgardner now it's a whole
new cast of deplorable characters not
the least of which is a gentleman named
Anthony skarra mucci a member of Donald
Trump's presidential transition team
he's an advisor to trump he went on CNN
he was being interviewed by Chris Cuomo
and there's basically two headlines from
this video one is getting a lot of
attention and one is not the first one
is that scar mucci compared believing
climate science to believing that the
earth is flat hundreds of years ago that
doesn't make any sense later he casually
referenced the age of the earth is 5500
years okay and that's making up the
fewer headlines and I want to talk about
that as well so let's start with this
stunning and wholesale lack of
understanding of anything these are the
types of deplorable that are going to be
making important decisions for the next
for years bear that in mind I think I
you know look I mean I know that the the
current President believes that the
human beings are affecting the climate
there are scientists that believe that
that's not happening i think that the
overwhelming consensus in the scientific
community is that present actions have
an impact on science race oh yeah i was
in her every woman whenever it comes up
coral had chris there was an
overwhelming science that the earth was
flat and there was an overwhelming side
interested to learn over time the Senate
we would wear this end center of the
world a hundred percent you know we get
a lot of things wrong in the scientific
community you and I both know that I'm
not suggesting that we're not affecting
the honestly don't know I'm not a
scientist you're asking me for my
opinion it's probably a blend of people
and what's going on in the Asscher a it
you're not as requested here I I hate
that he got interrupted there because he
was about to say something about what's
going on in the astronomical something
or other it was about to get even better
but he gets to the key thing at the end
Pat which is I'm not a scientist so then
why are you talking about why you think
the scientists are wrong if you're not a
scientist that's exactly why I liked
that he got interrupted because Chris
como had to step in there and say I
don't really care what your opinion is
it's fact no matter what you believe
it's not Chris Cuomo's opinion either
he's just saying here's what the
scientists say and what is this guy
talking about there was a quote
overwhelming science that the earth was
flat first of all there's no comparison
between flatter thurs and climate
science in 2016 flatter thurs we're not
operating on the scientific method that
we have today they were people like for
example Greek philosophers mostly pre
Socrates in the sixth 2 5th century BC
Aristotle provided evidence for the
spherical shape of the earth on
empirical grounds by around 330 BC and
worse Karamu Chi is particularly wrong
is that the most modern flat earther
stuff was not science getting it wrong
it was religion holding on to
non-science he gets it opposite yeah and
the consequences of being wrong about
something like geocentrism are pretty
small the consequences of him being
wrong on the climate that's drastic
especially the consequences of being
wrong about geocentrism or flat earth
when we don't even have the ability to
send up a
satellite or get off the planet at all
the Quonset consequences are essentially
zero compared to what we're talking
about with climate change and they're so
people who believe in those theories
there are a few there are a few yeah
that they're harder and harder fine
fortunately now here's where it gets
insane I I want to prepare I would get
the kids out of the room for this here
skarra mucci says that science has been
wrong during the long 5,500 years that
the planet earth has existed when I saw
this I couldn't stop laughing so does
president elect Trump and so do i I just
want you to understand it's not
ideological for me I'm just stating to
you what the proposition is from the
scientific community but it isn't but it
isn't for me but you science let me let
me just move on to something else though
which is I didn't say that i said i'm
not on you said you don't know i did not
saying the scientific advice needed oh
you you're saying that you do and you're
saying the scientific community knows
and i'm saying people have gotten things
wrong throughout the 5500 years three of
our planet I think indistinct the 5500
year history our planet check please I'm
out the door the earth is of course at
our best estimation 4.5 4 3 billion
years old now that may not be exact but
saying well it might be 4.5 billion it
might be 5,500 is like saying humans
don't need air to live that that that is
the point at which there is a disconnect
from the real world here the 5500 year
old earth thing seemed to sort of go
over Chris Cuomo's had maybe he needed
to move on or something like that that's
the headline from this to his credit he
did say human history but even that goes
back millions of years yeah right i mean
we're talking about you know several
hundred years of modern humans and then
early humans were talking about several
million years but of course that even a
fraction of the time that we're talking
about the age of the earth 4.5 billion
years old there is someone advising
Donald Trump who believes that our
planet is 5500 years old that should
scare anybody who can even put together
a coherent plot send me your thoughts
about this on
at you at the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the
day's groups passage Bruce thank you so
much for being a member of the David
Pakman show this is your show in the
sense that were mostly funded by you our
listeners our viewers on YouTube radio
podcast television etc please sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership and
this is not to try to get every last
dollar we can out of our audience if the
prices are too high by all means take
forty percent off with the coupon code i
voted 17 i want you involved but i want
you involved at a level that makes sense
for you financially so if the normal
prices are high i voted 17 all one word
all lower case use it and get a discount
really really appreciated let's talk
about what's going on on our reddit
discussion forum always like to check in
there and see what's happening david
pakman.com slash reddit re d di t now
more than 2,100 of our our viewers
regularly discussing politics there two
popular topics me taking off my shirt
and whether i trust the CIA came up on
the reddit discussion forum over the
last week let's take a look at a few of
the stories starting with anti-trump
elector Chrissa pruned paid for ashley
madison while bankrupt and married with
three kids this is a story that surface
to try to smear this Republican Trump
elector who announced he wouldn't be
voting Trump and my response was what
difference does it make what difference
does it make whether Christopher Supreme
was cheating if he feels that he should
not be voting for Donald Trump which is
something he can decide as an elector
another discussion from our ready
discussion forum why's David Pakman
trusting the CIA all of a sudden they
were after all very wrong about Iraq
listen uh I've made it very clear that
that is a false talking point okay we
have a situation where the George W Bush
administration misused the intelligence
from the CIA the CIA never actually said
hey we've got all the stuff that we know
for sure said
has that is a false talking point from
the right and you should be aware of it
another discussion from reddit at david
pakman.com slash reddit Trump Secretary
of State favorite Rex Tillerson praised
the trans-pacific partnership yeah a few
people have emailed me about this thing
David you know now that TPP is dead
supposedly tillerson is a guy who liked
it that may well be true I don't know
that tell erson praising TPP in the past
means it's going to be revived under
under Trump but we will see next
discussion from our reddit discussion
forum ideas to spice up the fundraiser
this was an interesting post with some
ideas for what we might be able to do on
the fundraiser of course mentioned in
there is that quote a lot of people seem
to want David to take his shirt off so
there is that also a lot of people
really want to see Louis well I'll say
two things about that number one I don't
know that a lot of people want to see me
take my shirt off I've I've heard it
from two people so far one via voicemail
and one on reddit and that may actually
be the same person and number two as far
as Louis Louis will be on today's bonus
show he is on his exploratory trip to
the southeast of the United States
hoping to find a new place to live uh
and we're going to be hearing from
producer louis today just to connect
those two points is it true that
producer louis once took his shirt off
on the show i think it is i I don't know
that it was that he took his shirt off
but I think he had on a hoodie and a
t-shirt under it and he wanted to show
the t-shirt or maybe it was to show his
tattoos and in the process of taking off
maybe maybe just the hoodie he exposed
the significant portion of his his
entire torso and I know that memberships
exploded that day the only day that
we've done that better on worship bad
today was the day after Donald Trump was
elected into a 16 so clearly it was a
big big deal ok I think we have one or
two more do we what one more one more
story but somebody posted some hilarious
photo shops of Donald Trump is the queen
of England but with the full hat and
everything you have to see these these
are very very visual these are really
good aren't they Pat I mean these are
fantastic pictures yet have you ever
seen clump a combination of Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton may have one face
that's fantastic it's the stuff of
nightmares I mean it's a very very scary
so anyway all of these discussions and
more happy
david pakman.com slash reddit i'm on
there regularly I see Pat mixing it up
in the discussion forum as well so check
it out sign up and it's all going to be
a very very exciting and continuing
there ok let's update you on the indy
gogo fundraiser at david pakman.com
slash donate which we are running to
really expand not only the david pakman
show but progressive activism at large
we have a new high water mark for the
top donation to our indiegogo campaign
before yesterday uh two hundred ninety
nine dollars was the top donation we
actually had to two hundred ninety nine
dollar donations we now have a new
leader that has emerged his name is
joshua and he came in with a four
hundred ninety nine dollar donation
absolutely huge huge thank you to joshua
the four hundred ninety nine dollar perk
happens to be ten discounted one-year
memberships so now joshua has these ten
memberships to give away to people and
joshua's really a mensch because he has
read own ated the ten memberships back
to the show to give away at some point
in the future that's huge Pat I mean
Joshua is an all-star right now we're
gonna have to come up with some way to
give out those memberships we are going
to and there will be plenty of time for
that I assure you also donations as
small as one dollar 31 dollar donations
62 dollar donations for three dollar
donations it all matters even if you
think you shouldn't contribute because
you can't contribute much that is not
the right way to think about it if
everybody who can donate even just one
two or three dollars at david pakman.com
slash donate does it then this campaign
will be over before you know it so
please if you can donate more than 499
help to set a new high mark for a single
donation for the campaign but most
importantly help us to continue to grow
the number of donors it's currently at a
hundred and eighty-four donors let's get
to 250 that's the next target for me and
real quick two new perks that are
available only through the david pakman
show fundraiser are custom designed
t-shirts
first of which I'm showing you on screen
is the established in 2005 t-shirt we've
determined that at the show's inception
in 2005 producer Pat was just two years
old and uh 11 I'm sorry I keep
forgetting this is an exclusive t-shirt
only available at david pakman.com slash
donate and for the first time ever we
have a hatred male t-shirt we've taken
one of the dozen or so hatred mail
graphics that we use during hey treat
male and turned it into a t-shirt talk
about a conversation piece again the hey
treat male t-shirt and the established
in 2005 t-shirt both only available at
david pakman.com slash donate Donald
Trump said that he would appoint a
special prosecutor to investigate
Democratic presidential nominee Hillary
Clinton's use of a private email server
you probably have heard that story
before that is probably not news to you
now during that time Donald Trump helped
to popularize the chant lock her up
however we recently heard from Donald
Trump that that was just election BS it
was something that plays well during the
campaign but that we don't care about it
now in other words what Trump met was it
something I said to get people excited
and to vote for me but I never really
planned to do it now a lot of this email
thing also extended to Trump's incoming
cabinet members and advisors in this
includes none other than retired Army
General Michael Flynn he condemned
Hillary Clinton's quote careless use of
a private private email server and said
that there was quote nothing wrong with
the lock her up chance let me put up a
quote for you from michael Flynn we're
saying that because if I a guy who knows
this business if i did a tenth a tenth
of what she did i would be in jail today
so so crooked Hillary Clinton leave this
race now well sometimes irony is sweet
but in some cases it's not because this
guy's still going to be national
security adviser it turns out that
michael Flynn did do a tenth of what
Hillary Clinton actually did Flynn
himself inappropriate
we shared classified information with
foreign military officers and officials
in Afghanistan in 2010 as the Washington
Post reported just 48 hours ago Flynn
wasn't authorized to share the
classified information he was not
authorized to share the particular
secrets that he divulged now Flynn was
asked about this and he said this is
insignificant uh this is nothing that we
need to worry about yet there are
numerous former US officials that are
familiar with exactly what Flynn did
which say that who say that he is
accused of telling a lies about the
activities of other agencies in
Afghanistan including the CIA this is
very serious but it gets even more
interesting Pat remember the Clinton
private email server situation Dana
priest wrote a profile of Flynn in The
New Yorker and reported that Flynn
quotes had technicians secretly install
and eat an internet connection in his
Pentagon office even though it was
forbidden well lock a lot right Pat but
you see I'm you know servers are more
likely to be hacked at home then you
know at my office because uh you know
hillary was a crook or something like
that yeah it's a total double standard
and also you remember General David
Petraeus shared very highly classified
information oh yeah not for the interest
of the public but just to show it off to
his biographer and his lover indeed and
Petraeus was considered for a long time
for Secretary of State someone should
alert jason Chaffetz because I'm sure
just like he started up a congressional
investigation into Hillary's email
scandal he'll start one into michael
Flynn right away right I mean we know he
takes this type of thing very very
seriously oh wait no it was all a
partisan witch hunt from the beginning
imagine if michael Flynn as part of the
trump administration exposed for example
classified information to one of our
adversaries like I don't know Russia or
something wait is Russia and adversary
now or they someone that half of trumps
cabinet is friendly with and would love
to do business with I don't know it's
changed so quickly since Mitt Romney
called Russia our greatest geopolitical
foe in 2012 that it's hard for me to
know whether Russia's even bad
now yeah I can't really answer that
question for you this is a very very hot
topic on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash reddit re di t
you can discuss this story or any others
from today's show there the david pakman
show at david pakman.com welcome back to
the david pakman show it's great to be
joined by attorney Mike Papantonio
co-host of ring of fire radio and also
the host of America's lawyer on RT which
premiered last night for people who
don't know the concept here Pat because
it's a really different concept for a
program what is it that people will see
on the show well there's so many stories
that a corporate media their advertisers
will not a order them don't tell these
stories basically if it's a
pharmaceutical that's killing people in
Pfizer's one of their advertisers or
merck is one of the advertisers say NBC
CBS ABC basically they get the they get
the order don't tell the story if it's
going to hurt sales uh so you you you
really can't tell stories that matter to
consumers if it's Wall Street who is
who's stealing from mom-and-pop
investors it's tough to tell that story
because Goldman Sachs and Morgan all of
the big folks on Wall Street are
advertising through corporate media same
way same way with environmental cases
you know if DuPont for example is
destroying an entire ecosystem you
really can't tell that story if you're
on corporate media because the
advertisers won't let you and I've had
first-hand experience with that I mean
where we were where I was told you know
we tried to tell a story about something
called yellow wood that we were talking
about the fact that it contained arsenic
and we were shut down immediately on
MSNBC yeah talk about that because you
were at the time a fair
the regular guest on MSNBC weren't you
and then you went on and you started
telling the story and all of a sudden it
was visit a year or more that you just
did not get invited back I think it
might have been a couple years yeah back
then I was doing in between there I was
doing fox news during the time I wasn't
I was a liberal on Fox yeah but I told
the story about something that was
called yellow wood and it was where they
were using this this wood that we
alleged and I think showed clearly i had
had content of arsenic in it but
unfortunately we're using the wood for
children's playgrounds and that kind of
wood is fine if you're building a
foundation for a house that you know you
don't want the wood dorado if you're
building a pier that reaches out into
into waterway that that's good it
actually works for that but the point is
you don't use that for children's
playgrounds and so we did a segment out
as Joe Scarborough and I did a segment
and the next day we I got a call from
Phil Griffin whose well I I didn't Joe
got the call from phil griffin saying
what's what's up here and it was almost
as if we had to go back on and do a
recount the story which I which I refuse
to do and so that's pretty typical of
what you run into with corporate media
there it's all about money they they
have no responsibility to to really
telling investigative stories I mean
just look at the tobacco problem where
you had 60 minutes that we even hedged
on telling the story about tobacco and
the dangers of how it causes cancer and
if that's even after the the CEOs for 12
different companies raise the right hand
and committed perjury from the Congress
lied to Congress about the dangers but
still you can't get you cannot get
corporate media to tell these stories
anymore oftentimes that's how somebody
about a legal show they imagine you know
a panel of four people yelling about
whether someone is guilty or not guilty
of some depraved crime against kids or
something like that america's lawyer is
a totally different type of legal show i
mean you're talking about specific
corporations and you're talking about
some of the cases that attorneys are
involved in can you give us a couple of
examples
what we can for example the first show
we talked about Johnson & Johnson's talc
powder where we actually showed the
documents that came from their file
cabinets that showed that they
absolutely knew of the dangers of
ovarian cancer relating to tout powder
so we don't just I begin the show David
with a short opening statement about six
or seven minutes but in there I'm
actually showing the documents that I'm
relying on I'm not not asking anybody to
take my word for anything we actually
show them the documents and then we move
right into the lawyer who might be
handling it and they talk more about the
documents and what's showing up in court
so we started off with that case we
started off with Erin Brockovich on the
Flint Michigan cover-up and we actually
we focused on the idea that you had Rick
Snyder up there that was that was
covering up the dangers of this water
that children were drinking by the
gallons for a year and the amount of
lead that was contained in it why it was
covered up how it was covered up and
Erin Brockovich handled that issue so
that we it's kind of gloves it's totally
gloves off David there's no there's
nothing warm and fuzzy about what we do
we go after the other side and then we
end the story we in the show talking
about the good the positive stories that
are out there where there's been great
developments in the law on behalf of
consumers and again consumers simply
don't have a chance to hear those
stories either how is your legal
community given the types of cases that
that you work on and try preparing for
the incoming Trump administration and by
that I mean you know for example the
Dakota access pipeline which both Donald
Trump and incoming a secretary of energy
Rick Perry have financial connections to
Scott Pruett at the EPA a guy charged
with environmental protection who has a
multi-decade record of doing the exact
opposite i mean do you think that there
are implications in terms of the work
that you do from the incoming cabinet
well it's just going to create a lot of
work I mean we've been through this
before for example after the Bush
administration we started seeing more
pharmaceutical cases where dangerous
drugs were killing people literally by
the thousands whether it was a birth
control pill that was causing and it was
causing blood clots or excuse me that
was causing strokes and women whether it
was an anticoagulant drug that was
causing their supposed to be used to
avoid blood clots that was causing death
and people by just bleeding bleeding out
so we saw a lot of that come out of the
bush administration and oddly enough
Clinton as well because there was such
an effort to deregulate their FDA was
the the the FDA was basically neutered
in their ability to be able to do
anything and they voluntarily
participated with the pharmaceutical
industry because they were getting jobs
you see they would FDA would get a job
they would move through the process and
they would say yeah we're going to allow
this drug to go on the market next thing
you know that person is working with a
drug company so we're going to see the
same thing and it's going to be the
younger lawyers of five six seven years
from now they have to clean up this mess
again in the meantime we're gonna go to
court every time we have to slow
everything down as much as possible as
far as america's lawyer is concerned you
know anytime that there's a program that
that starts a savvy media consumer would
say okay well let's explore what
conflicts of interest could arise based
on the advertisers on that program
that's going to be very specifically not
an issue with with america's lawyer
isn't it no no that's one reason
obviously I agree agreed to do this I
mean there is no conflict of interest at
all I mean we're not you know obviously
some of the cases that we're talking
about we're going to be involved with
because we've been doing this for 35
years it will be we will have tried some
of those cases but you don't have to
take our word for it we'll have people
besides such me talking about the case
and as far as advertising they don't
they don't really advertise that that's
they have the same advantage of the BBC
hat or whether they're able to tell a
story without having an advertiser make
a telephone call saying you have to take
that story down because it's going to
affect sales it's really odd right now
you're in the midst of you know you've
got the Democrats primarily beating on
Russia for hacking weed there's at this
point I think you conclude the same
thing I have there's all this innuendo
not a Miss anonymous there's anonymous
that
so far I've seen no proof of anything
but nevertheless it's a good talking
point for the Democrats who feel like
they have to blame the fire failure
election on the FBI call me on Bernie
Sanders on Wikileaks on Russians on
progressive media on the misogynist on
Millennials on fake news I mean we've
seen it all yeah I think I you know I
think I agree with you on in terms of
you know there's plenty of blame here
that should be inward looking at the
same time you know I've disagreed with
the the right-wing idea that hey that
the CIA was wrong on Iraq and we can't
trust them now either on this Russia
thing because it's sort of a false
notion that the Bush administration
misused what the CIA had actually said
so that talking point specifically i
think is one that's being really misused
by by the right to discredit the CIA
unfairly i don't know what you think of
that well my response is the CIA is not
a moot bunch of morons I mean they had
the right to speak up they didn't speak
up even after they even after Powell in
rice showed up in front of the UN with
this fraud game that they played about
about yellowcake uranium they knew the
lie yeah and they chose to keep their
mouth shut in thousands tens and tens of
thousands of people died because of it I
have very little respect for the CIA
very little and I'm not equating this
with it but you know it's not just it's
just not people like me that are
doubting the CIA it's it's the FBI
doubting the CIA it's the it's the it's
an organization that runs all of the
security entities that say we're not
buying into this Russian hacking so we
have to see more I mean and I and I I
think it makes me angry the angries to
see the Democrats using this is some
type of prop by we as far as why here we
failed it's in sensing to me yep i agree
with you i mean that the bottom line is
even if all of the allegations are true
if you didn't have such a candidate with
this level of baggage fifty-eight
thousand votes in three states would not
have swung the election to begin with
that sort of where i end up on it
exactly not only that but it's kind of a
misdirection david we see it in court
all the time where the defense lawyer we
present these horrible documents and the
defense to the dot defense to the case
is well yeah
these documents are bad but let's talk
about where Papantonio got those
documents is there that matters you see
that the emails were horrible and so
rather than addressing that they want to
blame it on somebody else yet to me it's
just insane and unfortunately
rank-and-file Democrats are buying into
it and it's making them look foolish
america's lawyer premiered on RT last
night we've been speaking with the
show's host attorney Mike Papantonio
always great to talk to you thank you I
appreciate the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
you
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
I told you earlier this week about
Donald Trump explaining why he doesn't
need daily intelligence briefings
because he's quote smart he's quote like
a smart person and we will first before
I tell you the latest news which
involves former CIA director Leon
Panetta I'll remind you what he said to
Chris Wallace over the weekend you are
getting the presidential Daily Brief
this only once a week well I I get it
when I need it is that if they're so
special first of all these are very good
people that are giving me the briefings
and I say if something should change
from this point immediately call me I'm
available on one minute's notice yeah I
don't have to be told you know like a
smart person I don't have to be told the
same thing in the same words every
single day for the next eight years a
bunch of people wrote in Pat after we
ran the story and they said you know
Trump said he's like a smart person he
didn't say he is a smart person which is
just sort of a linguistic uh a
convention that I'm like a smart person
but literally interpreted he said I'm
similar to a smart person but not
exactly saying he is a smart person and
I think that's more of a correct
assessment than just saying he is a
smart person I think you're right and it
seems that if we asked a former defense
secretary and CIA director Leon Panetta
whether anything from said there makes
any sense the answer would be no he was
asked about this issue in a as / Reuters
and he said the following about Trump
taking the daily briefing only once per
week I've seen presidents who have asked
questions about whether that
intelligence is verifiable what are the
sources for that intelligence but I have
never said it seen a president who said
I don't want that stuff if we endure
another attack and the intelligence
officials had indications or information
regarding that attack and the President
did not want to listen to that for
whatever reason the responsibility for
that attack would fall on the president
Leon Panetta is completely right if
Trump makes it a habit of not taking the
daily intelligence briefing and there is
an attack against the United States it
would be perfectly reasonable to hold
Trump at least partially responsible but
don't delude yourselves rational
thinkers we know who's going to be
blamed for any attack during Donald
Trump's administration I'll give you one
s Pat I'm sure you can get it right who
would be blamed if it if an attack
happens during the trump administration
Hillary Clinton now Barack Obama right
clothes that would have been the second
option and and that it's a good
assessment as well anything that happens
during the Trump administration is going
to be blamed on the conditions left
behind for Donald Trump by President
Obama and we have evidence of this
remember President Obama has been break
blamed for a hurricane katrina 911 these
are events that happened before he was
president it even happened at Donald
Trump rallies where people were blaming
President Obama for how he handled 911
seemingly clueless that President Obama
was not president when 911 happened I
did have one idea of how we might be
able to get Trump to pay attention to
the daily intelligence briefings do them
on Saturday Night Live because Trump
seems to be watching that regularly or
maybe have like an Eastern European
model of working in a in the US before
being authorized to presenting him the
briefings those are two ideas I have and
apparently the intelligence community is
trying to come up with a way to make
this information more interesting to him
yeah and I guess from what we learned
from a number of people who have
interviewed Trump if you're having a
conversation with Trump and there's a TV
on in the background Trump will pay a
ton of attention to that TV so maybe the
people who briefed Trump can come into
his office but then just play the
briefing on a TV in the background or
something like that Trump's probably
more likely to start getting
intelligence briefings daily when the
intelligence agencies are staffed
exclusively with people smart enough to
only tell Trump what he wants to hear
maybe Ted Nugent as the for future FBI
director or something like that uh at
least Bush 43 was receiving his Intel
briefings I mean yes he ignored one
particular one called Osama bin Laden
determined to strike within the US but
he was at least getting them right yeah
that's the thing I mean God forbid some
sort of attack did happen you would like
to at least look back and take solace in
the fact that you did everything you
could to prevent it and if you're not
taking every briefing that is offered
how could you possibly feel like you did
everything you could and you everything
that you could have known this is a
systemic and fundamental danger I know
we like to joke around about it but this
is truly scary stuff or
earlier this week MSNBC did something
interesting they did a town hall called
the Trump country in Kenosha Wisconsin
Chris Hayes was the host of it and they
had senator and former presidential
candidate Bernie Sanders attend now
before I even tell you the story if
you're watching with me this expression
on Bernie Sanders is face that you see
in the picture that we're displaying
this expression tells you everything you
need to know about how this thing went
and I'm going to start with Vermont
senator Bernie Sanders calmly walking a
trump voter through how Republicans are
planning to gut the social safety net
this Trump voter insisted that no one's
listening to small town voters like her
and actually started saying we're paying
into all of these things uh and and I'm
concerned that we're paying in and
paying in and we're not getting out what
we should be getting out this applies to
taxes and Social Welfare etcetera which
is actually sort of sort of a
progressive idea in many ways let's
start with this uh uh and you will see
how she doesn't even realize as Bernie
Sanders astutely explains to her if
these are your views you voted for the
guy who doesn't agree with what you are
saying Bernie Sanders explains it very
very clearly to her and she agrees with
Bernie but you can tell she doesn't
really get that she voted against her
own best interest by voting for Trump
take a look at this okay but down here
good good point let's let's see if we
did i'll throw it on this i'm assuming
that you believe correct me if I'm wrong
that we should not cut social security
or medicare or medicaid is that correct
one on yeah okay i believe it shouldn't
be cut okay do you know who was now
working very hard to try to do that
Republicans in Congress have a plan
under the guise of saving Medicare and
saving Social Security making
devastating cuts that's publicans are
now trying to do the other point that
you made which is a very I think you bet
it was you both of you made it actually
is who's going to pay for this stuff and
that is a very fair point
what all of us should know is that over
the last 25 years there has been a
massive transfer of wealth in this
country from you to the top one-tenth of
1% in other words the middle class has
shrunk and trillions of dollars have
gone to the top one-tenth of one percent
do you think it's inappropriate to ask
those people to stop paying their fair
share of taxes so we can adequately fund
Medicaid in making public colleges and
universities tuition-free is that an
unfair thing pass I don't think it's an
unfair for yeah that's right so it's
time they put back okay all right well
I'm sorry Bernie Sanders visibly
perplexed that's just the best isn't it
she still has no idea that she voted for
the wrong person based on what you want
to see heaven yeah it upsets me in a way
because this guy would have beaten Trump
I'm pretty sure of that they the people
wanted a populist they didn't want some
hack like Hillary Clinton here's one
other great moment where they are all
saying that we can ignore all the crazy
stuff Trump said during the campaign
because it wasn't true and Bernie
Sanders points out you're defending
Trump by saying we should have all just
understood he was lying during the
campaign it's an amazing moment take a
look there's no question to my mind I
find it interesting that what three out
of four of you are saying is yeah he
talked about that stuff but it'll never
happen we don't believe that it will
ever happen uh why do you vote for
somebody who in a sense than his lines
[Applause]
inserting a dialogue with the American
people and he used the media to get his
point across and hinges but he wasn't
like he started the dialogue he voiced
his opinion and he he got feedback and
he addressed it as he went along he
knows as well as anybody in this room
you can't go after a group of people
because of religious beliefs it's never
and I knew that right off the bat but he
was still upright he talked to the
public what's an interesting point I
mean what you're saying is that you
think and I think that what he was
talking about was unconstitutional you
got a candidate for president of the
United States talking about grossly
unconstitutional things and wins an
election well look what our Congress
does it's an everyday watching this did
make me realize Pat that these people
cannot be taught you can't make
individuals that are this committed to
nonsense understand there is no argument
to be made we just need to outnumber
them through voter turnout the if we
want to figure out how to win elections
as progresses having conversations with
folks like this and trying to change
their minds it's not going to be nearly
as effective as just go vote and
Bernie's logic on these things always
gets portrayed as pie in the sky is very
straightforward in took this woman only
a minute or so to be persuaded it took
her only a minute to be persuaded that
she agreed with Bernie but I think
what's missing is the connection that
all maybe she should have voted for
someone else because the person she
voted for wants the opposite of what she
just said makes sense that's the missing
piece though and you should vote for
someone who actually believes in what
they say yeah well that so I mean you
wow wow Pat that sounds like a really
crazy thing we have a voicemail number
it's 2192 david p i don't know if this
is the first voicemail exclusively
focused on Pat maybe it is think so okay
let's take a listen man pat has been on
fire lately every video i see he's out
there making good points and he's really
become more confident since he first
started the show keep up the good work
all right Pat we have a positive Pat
voicemail now and I'm sure you have to
be prepared that there will be now in
response negative Pat voicemails but
that's okay i am prepared i mean there
are growing pains I
think I'm getting through them all right
on the bonus show today we will hear
about pat's jury duty yesterday Pat was
out yesterday because of jury duty also
former producer Louis is calling in from
I believe is in Florida although he may
have moved into into Georgia now he's on
an exploratory mission to the southeast
of the United States we're going to be
talking to him extensively big league on
today's bonus show so if you're not a
member sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership you can use coupon code I
voted 17 to get a discount and please
please please please please donate at
david pakman.com slash donate can have a
major indiegogo crowdfunding campaign
and i would love for you to be a part
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you